merci d'être avec nous jean-y je compte
être nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure vous êtes sénateur
représentant les Français établis hors
de France membres du groupe socialiste
et on va évidemment parler de
l'actualité de votre partie puisque
c'était jour de vote il y a pour les
militants socialistes appelé à choisir
entre trois textes d'orientation celui
d'Olivier forces le premier secrétaire
sortant celui de Nicolas Mayer Rossignol
et celui d'Hélène Geoffroy que vous
soutenez Olivier Faure et donc arrivé en
tête qu'en pensez-vous
c'est pas vraiment une surprise on sait
pas encore s'il est majoritaires
complets ou pas mais contrairement à ce
que ce qu'indiquait votre petit
reportage ce n'était pas inscrit un pour
le choix du premier secrétaire c'était
vraiment le choix des textes
orientations
juste pour que les spectateurs
comprennent bien hier vous les militants
étaient appelés à choisir pour les
textes d'orientation et la semaine
prochaine c'est la première arrivée en
tête
le le ce qui est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle c'est effectivement
le nombre de personnes qui ont voté lors
de ce scrutin dans les différentes
fédérations et puis oui enfin
du premier secrétaire mais quand même
ces textes d'orientation étaient portés
par des personnes c'est-à-dire que les
votes se sont quand même portés sur
Olivier fort logiquement l'élection de
la semaine prochaine du premier
secrétaire mais voilà là c'est on
constitue une part du Conseil national
de cette manière
vous avez vu le débat de la semaine
dernière si le débat de la semaine
dernière n'a pas montré derrière bien
entendu quand on se présente et qu'on
est sur des lignes différentes on
accentue ce qui vous fait ce qui vous
différencie de l'autre mais
fondamentalement vous avez vu que
pendant le débat il y avait pas voilà
c'était c'est pas un bec des des
objections fondamentales et mais moi qui
est soutenu et qui soutient le texte des
LED Geoffroy je peux dire que Olivier
fort a effectivement fait quand il a
fait en sorte que l'ensemble des parties
de gauche
puisse finalement retrouver la capacité
de travailler ensemble et d'avoir
confiance les uns dans les autres et
qu'on se retrouve lors de la campagne
législative bon je suis un petit peu
binoritaire dans mon texte d'orientation
parce qu'effectivement il y en avait qui
était vraiment opposé à la du pesto j'ai
considéré que finalement se retrouver
pour pouvoir faire une campagne ensemble
et c'était une belle campagne défensive
offensive on aurait gagné on aurait
quand on voit l'actualité on aurait
besoin de la gauche au pouvoir mais une
belle campagne défensive on s'est
redécouvert les uns les autres entre les
parties maintenant il faut travailler
c'est pas le le il faut travailler pour
avoir un vrai projet pas être simplement
pour dire votez pour nous parce que
regarder sinon ce qui va se passer sur
la réforme des traitements ça suffit pas
il faut dire ce qu'on veut faire et là
il y a besoin de travailler il y a
besoin de travailler entre les
différents partis de gauche pour passer
finalement de la nups qui est un peu
voilà un truc où il y a les filles et
puis un accord entre les filles et
chaque partie c'est pas encore quelque
chose où on sait tous mis ensemble pour
discuter de nos orientations et de de ce
que vous voulez faire on l'a fait au
niveau de chaque circonscription donc
maintenant il faut aller plus loin et il
y a pas très honnêtement il y a pas de
de différence fondamentale sur sur les
principales journaux vous l'avez vu dans
le débat donc il faut pas non plus
dramatiser non mais il y avait quand
même trois lignes différentes notamment
vis-à-vis de la nuque on va y revenir
mais vous vous le soutenez hier Hélène
Geoffroy vous l'avez déjà aucune
divergence sur l'union de la gauche on
va en parler mais vous soutenir vous
soutenez Geoffroy pour qui vous voterez
la jeudi prochain entre Olivier fort et
Nicolas Mayer rossignol
écoutez je ne peux pas vous le dire pour
l'instant je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
c'est pas automatique
des gens qui ont voté pour Hélène
Geoffroy et Nicolas Mayer rossignoles en
tout cas personnellement pour moi ce
n'est pas automatique
je il y a ce sont tous des camarades
nous avons et donc par conséquent je
peux pas à ce stade vous le dire
l'important c'est que pour moi
l'essentiel c'est d'avoir un parti et
qui est dans une situation où il ne se
satisfait pas de ce qui a été fait on
dit bon on a encore une pièce maintenant
on a fait l'union de la gauche c'est bon
on a un accord électoral et puis quand
il y a une dissolution pourra repartir
non c'est pas comme ça on a besoin de
construire des propositions et pour
construire des propositions on a
vraiment besoin de débattre au sein de
l'ensemble de la gauche donc je verrais
bien celui des deux qui propose la
meilleure manière de de faire pour que
toute la gauche parce que vous voyez
bien il y a même des chaussures
démocrates ou des gens qui se disent qui
ne sont pas aux parties socialiste les
principales divergences les principaux
débats au sein de la gauche ils sont
même plus entre nos parties ils sont
parfois au sein de nos parties entre
différentes manières de voir les choses
il y a je crois vraiment que nous devons
trouver le moyen de travailler ensemble
à gauche pour construire un projet mais
c'est un peu paradoxal avec votre
soutien et Hélène Geoffroy parce que
celui qui était plutôt dans un en même
temps c'est Nicolas mayor Rossignol chez
Hélène Geoffroy il est plutôt clair que
c'était antinhup
c'était anti-up
si on considère que la nuque et l'alpha
et l'oméga de l'union de la gauche oui
si par contre on considère que et elle
le fait dans sa ville et il y a
énormément de de personnes qui ont
soutenu les mêmes Geoffroy qui
lorsqu'ils sont dans leur territoire ça
faire travailler ensemble de la gauche
mais ça fait à travers l'ensemble de la
gauche sur des projets pas simplement
sur le fait que on est de gauche donc on
est ensemble parce que ça ça convainc
pas une majorité pour vous le vote
d'hier et le fait qu'Olivier fort soit
arrivé en tête ça valide pas sa
stratégie de la nuque c'est un peu ce
qui dit dans son tweet cette nuit
de manière un peu décalée peut-être par
rapport à certains membres de mon texte
d'orientation je lui reconnais vraiment
l'avoir d'avoir pu d'une part sauver les
meubles à un moment où c'était difficile
et deuxièmement avoir permis aux
différentes forces de gauche de
retrouver confiance en elle-même et en
tout cas et que le Parti socialiste soit
intégré à ça
donc ça c'est un acquis maintenant c'est
à qui il est pas suffisant pour gagner
et je n'ai pas vu dans son texte ce qui
était de nouveau par rapport à cet
accord défensif d'une certaine manière
de juin 2022 on pouvait peut-être pas
faire autre chose sauf que maintenant il
faut faire autre chose il faut que les
militants qui sont partis les militants
de gauche qui sont dans différents
partis puissent construire ensemble un
projet qui a une vocation à avoir une
majorité en France
puisque je le disais vous représentez
les Français de l'étranger qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé hier avec le vote des
Français de l'étranger qui a été annulé
une erreur majeure du prestataire
qui a mis quasiment à disposition des
observateurs des différents textes
d'orientation la possibilité d'avoir
l'ensemble des codes pour voter pour
l'ensemble des personnes donc à partir
de là c'était quand même difficile de
comprendre
la situation de la Fédération avec des
personnes qui sont réparties sur
l'ensemble du monde c'est difficile de
faire autrement même si à titre
personnel je trouve logis je trouvais
logique que lorsqu'il y a des sections
on puisse d'abord voter en section mais
voilà donc c'est une erreur majeure du
prestataire et c'est vrai que c'est très
triste parce que je après
et c'est c'est le risque parce que
finalement c'est une expression qui
n'est pas qui se passe pas correctement
et bien entendu en plus comme il y a eu
quand même des une campagne très vive de
la part de certains bien entendu
un vote un second vote qui ne se passe
pas dans la sérénité dans les bonnes
explications un mot sur la réforme des
retraites puisqu'on l'a vu à la
mobilisation se prépare des syndicats du
côté de la gauche alors vous dites il y
a pas beaucoup de différence entre nous
mais là quand même sur les retraites il
y a des différences il y a d'un côté
Olivier Faure qui est d'accord avec
l'accord de la nuque à 60 ans et de
l'autre côté notamment chez les
Sénateurs beaucoup de sénateurs qui sont
favorables au maintien à 62 ans quel est
votre position la retraite la réforme
des retraites on en retient que l'âge
mais il n'y a pas que là j'ai énormément
de disposition et
ce que l'ensemble de la gauche
veut c'est une
meilleure prise en compte de la
pénibilité ce qui avait été adopté en
partie lors de la réforme Touraine et
qui a été en partie supprimé par
Emmanuel Macron bien entendu à partir du
moment où on n'est pas tous eu uniforme
on a des idées différentes l'idéal ce
serait la réforme à 60 ans après bon
on fait le réel c'est 62 ans c'est ça il
y a des gens qui se disent ben on a
adopté une on on veut être par rapport à
ce qu'on a voté lors de la réforme
Touraine ce qui nous rassemblent ceux
qui nous rassemble c'est la volonté de
prendre la pénibilité le mieux possible
dans le les exigences de nombre d'années
nécessaires pour avoir une retraite à
taux plein je pense aussi qu'il y a des
éléments dans une réforme des retraites
qui pourraient être utile
vous avez des carrières qui sont de plus
en plus hachés et qui font appel à des
régimes de retraite différents
aujourd'hui contenus des modes de calcul
contenu des modes de calcul et des 25
meilleures années dans un régime bien
entendu si vous êtes poly pensionnés
vous êtes tout à fait défavorisés il y a
de plus en plus de polypensionnés il y a
eu une réforme des traites qui très très
correctement la situation des polypes
pensionnés elle est importante et bien
entendu j'y suis particulièrement
sensible parce qu'on représentant les
Français à l'étranger je sais aussi tous
ceux qui ont une partie de leur retraite
à l'étranger c'est à dire qu'ils
n'auront pas les les les le nombre
d'années nécessaires en France pour
avoir un taux plein et il est absolument
indispensable que leurs années cotisées
à l'étranger puissent permettre aussi
d'être intégrés dans le calcul de
manière systématique on va parler de
l'actualité du Sénat cette semaine
c'était notamment cette audition d'Eric
Dupond-Moretti sur son plan de justice
on voit ça avec notre journaliste
parlementaire qu'en tant qu'elle met
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
le compte et Quentin le ministre de la
Justice a donc présenté cette semaine
une feuille de route pour son ministère
et un prochain projet de loi voilà il
était effectivement reçu cette semaine
au Sénat il a parlé d'un projet de loi
au printemps prochain Oriane parmi les
principales mesures qui concernent la
justice une nouvelle hausse du budget de
7 milliards sur 5 ans et le recrutement
de 10000 fonctionnaires dont 1500
magistrats et 1500 greffiers en 5 ans
a-t-il dit nous aurons recruté autant de
magistrats que durant ces 20 dernières
années ouais écoutez un extrait de
Freddie Eric Dupond-Moretti devant les
sénateurs cette semaine nous voulons
bien sûr embaucher nous voulons
construire des établissements
pénitentiaires vous le savez moderniser
agrandir les palais de justice
numériser madame la sénatrice la justice
et
revaloriser les agents du ministère
parmi les chantiers on voit ici et bien
une refonte de la justice civile le
ministre veut développer la politique de
l'amiable vous allez nous dire ce que
vous en pensez jean-luconte mais l'idée
c'est de davantage impliquer les
justiciables dans la résolution des
contentieux on écoute l'explication des
règles Dupond-Moretti donc système que
je souhaite mettre en place
le juge intervient pour trancher d'abord
la question de droit parce que dans ces
affaires il y a une question de droit
une question de fait la question de
droit il intervient avant cette mise en
état insupportablement longue et quand
la question de droit est tranchée alors
il incite il invite les parties à
trouver un accord alors autre thème il y
a aussi parlé de la modernisation de la
procédure pénale à droite constant
veut-il cette refonte doit
spécifiquement et bien prévoir la
simplification des cadres d'enquête
c'est parmi les grandes annonces que
l'on a entendu ces derniers jours des
risques Dupont-Moretti alors cette
révision du code de la procédure pénale
s'inquiète les sénateurs de la
commission des lois écoutez à notre
micro le président de cette commission
François Nuel buffet
une réforme pénale ça ne se fait pas sur
un coin de table au ministère sans
contrôle du Parlement ou son
participation active du Parlement nous
préférons avoir un texte déposé par le
garde des sceaux et que le Parlement
sont saisis et le traite c'est pas la
méthode qui a été retenue alors il y en
a plus en début de c'est en début de
l'audition en début de d'audition
définitivement pas la méthode retenue en
fin d'audition on semblait qu'il pouvait
peut-être y avoir des évolutions
alors un mot sur toutes ces annonces
j'arrive le compte d'abord sur le budget
vous ne pouvez à mon avis que saluer
cette évolution bien entendu sur la
question du
sur la question du budget je crois que
c'est absolument indispensable je l'ai
indiqué en audition nous sommes nombreux
parmi les sénateurs de la commission des
lois faire des faits des des stages
d'immersion dans des juridictions et
nous avons vu combien c'était difficile
en termes de moyens en termes de moyens
d'équipement en termes de moyens en
personnel et et la charge de travail en
particulier et des magistrats et des
greffiers avec des personnels qui qui
nous disaient dans des difficultés ils
étaient c'est-à-dire qu'on avait
vraiment l'impression d'un service
public qui avait lui dans les acteurs
avaient eux-mêmes conscience que
finalement il n'arrivait plus à le tenir
donc il y a vraiment besoin de
délabrement de la justement et c'est
donc à rattrapage absolument absolument
indispensable d'avoir effectivement ces
augmentations de de moyens donc
1500 greffiers ça ce sont des mesures
c'est c'est indispensable le garde de
saut indiqué combien c'était aussi un
important voilà qu'on pouvait pas le
faire du jour au lendemain parce que une
question de formation donc ces aspects
là bien entendu nous sommes d'accord sur
la question de la justice civile c'est
vrai que bien entendu quand il y a deux
parties il y en a peut-être une qui a
intérêt à faire durer les choses
toutefois la justice civile c'est de va
être crédible justement parce que elle
doit être juste elle doit être rapide et
effectivement on constate qu'aujourd'hui
ça n'est pas le cas donc ce qu'il
propose de de ce côté-là et bien alors
par contre dans votre présentation quand
vous parlez de de de des réformes
pénales il y a deux choses qui ont été
la différence entre la réforme pénale
c'est la réflexion sur les peines oui et
et la procédure pénale oui tout à fait
mais donc en fait sur la procédure
pénale en fait il a surtout indiqué que
on simplifierait le code pas
nécessairement les procédures en
elle-même mais la manière dont on doit
les comprendre quand on doit agir oui
alors on va y revenir mais un mois
encore sur la justice civile l'idée
c'est de s'inspirer de ce qui se passe
au Pays-Bas ou au Québec vous vous êtes
sénateurs des français établi en France
est-ce que vous avez vu des modèles sur
justice civils qui fonctionnent mieux
dans d'autres pays écoutez je dors parce
que en fait j'ai pas fait de comparaison
internationale sur l'ensemble des sujets
malheureusement
c'est en partie mon rôle mais je peux
pas le faire sur tous les sujets donc là
je peux pas vous dire très bien et alors
du coup sur la réforme du code de pénal
dont vous parliez également l'idée que
le Parlement puisse davantage encadrer
cette refonte ça c'est quelque chose
aussi qui est nécessaire comme François
Noel buffet vous voulez ça ne se passe
pas
c'est c'est vrai lorsque que que que si
on vous dit on va jamais le code à droit
constant et donc en demande d'une une
habilitation par ordonnance bon c'est
vrai que dans ces cas là c'est quand
même une opération compliqué et qui a
vraiment besoin de faire en sorte que
l'habilitation de toute façon elle doit
être votée par le Parlement et c'est
bien et ça serait correct que ce soit
derrière effectivement réellement
ratifié de manière formelle par un
projet de loi qui non seulement déposé
mais qui est discuté au Parlement pour
le reste pour la réforme bien-être bien
entendu parce que cela pour le coup
c'est quand même le le fond des choses
le législateur doit bien entendu
réfléchir sur la manière dont la
politique pénale du pays j'ai une
dernière question voilà question rien
effectivement on avait vu le désarroi de
la profession lors des états généraux de
la justice les plus homagistrats
également François Molin qui avait pris
la parole est-ce que toutes ces annonces
depuis la semaine dernière de guerre des
sceaux selon vous ça peut permettre de
répondre efficacement à ce désarroi moi
je crois qu'on est arrivé à un moment où
sur ces sujets
compte tenu de l'état de délabrement
la dernière chance parce
qu'effectivement il y a eu la croisée
des chemins aujourd'hui il y a une belle
démarche d'écoute le le tout ce qu'il y
a tout ce qui était de la part des
justifiable de la part des acteurs de la
justice tout a été dit ça a été bien
résumé ce que fait je marque sauvé
particulièrement remarquable puis après
voilà qui a pris
les états généraux de la justice le
rendu a été très intéressant par contre
maintenant si en phase de d'action on
n'arrive pas à délivrer correctement là
pour le coup il y aura un vrai problème
de crédibilité et il y a quand même un
sujet c'est à dire que ce que le garde
de Sceaux peut faire dans le cadre de
son ministère il l'a fait
mais il y a quand même une énorme
critique les normes critiques c'est que
ce qui dépend du président de la
République n'est pas fait c'est-à-dire
que quand même et Jean-Marc Sauvé l'a
dit dans son audition il y a un sujet
majeur c'est l'indépendance du parquet
c'est la réforme de la de du Conseil
Supérieur juste
changer la constitution attendez le
texte a été adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale par le Sénat il suffit que le
Président de la République décide de
faire cette réforme pour rendre le
parquet
de manière plus indépendante contenue
des compétences qu'il a on sait que
c'est une réforme indispensable les
états généraux de la justice non dit il
ne le fait pas alors c'est bien entendu
pas une décision propre du garde des
sceaux on sait aussi par des
informations par des interventions qu'il
avait fait précédemment qui est
favorable mais le président de la
République sur ce sujet ne fait rien et
bien voilà quand votre point de
vigilance là-dessus merci à tout à
l'heure on reviendra sur ce qui se passe
au Parti socialiste ce sera dans une
demi-heure dans le club d'abord on va
voir l'actualité dans nos régions on va
aller à Vichy dans l'Allier retrouver
Mathieu Perino bonjour Mathieu merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous responsable de
l'agence de Vichy pour le journal La
Montagne au sujet dont on va parler avec
vous puisque vous revenez sur la pénurie
d'amoxicilline qui touche la France
ouais je vous emmène ce matin dans une
pharmacie d'Issoire une petite commune
du Puy-de-Dôme alors depuis trois
semaines la petite équipe de 4 personnes
a un peu bouleversé son quotidien pour
fabriquer un antibiotique l'amoxicilline
alors la moxicilline les parents
connaissent c'est un antibiotique
prescrit aux enfants pour traiter les
otites ou les angines bactériennes et
depuis des mois c'est la pénurie d'un
côté la production de ce médicament à
diminuer depuis le covid de l'autre la
demande a explosé plus de 63 millions de
boîtes vendus en 2022 contre 43 millions
en 2020 les industriels n'avaient pas
anticipé et la production ne suit pas à
l'arrivée cet antibiotique est devenu
très rare et pour éviter une pénurie
trop lourde l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament a donc lancé un
appel un appel à l'aide aux pharmacies
pour la fabrication de cet antibiotique
elles sont à peu près une quarantaine en
France à le faire alors on sait
l'importance de la question de la
souveraineté pharmaceutique depuis la
pandémie et le retard que doit rattraper
la France en la matière le chemin reste
long très long on le voit quand les
industriels ne savent plus faire quand
l'État ne sait plus faire les officines
viennent à la rescousse mais c'est
évidemment pas une solution durable dans
ma question monsieur le sénateur que
peut faire le pays pour retrouver cette
souveraineté pharmaceutique et est-ce
que c'est seulement possible
oui bien entendu d'abord effectivement
il y a des situations qui peut
s'expliquer en particulier par le fait
que sur un certain nombre de médicaments
quand ils sont génériques en particulier
ils sont produits ils sont produits à
l'étranger et c'est sur ces bases là qui
est éventuellement les remboursements
sont faits donc à partir de là ça vaut
plus la peine de les produire en France
à des tarifs plus élevés donc il y a une
réflexion sur le fait on peut pas être
on peut pas vouloir être souverain et
pas vouloir donner le prix après aux
produits donc il y a un sujet sur mais
c'est comme c'est d'une certaine manière
c'est comme la question de des déserts
médicaux depuis qu'on a voulu réguler
finalement la médecine en régulant
l'offre on a des difficultés et ou 30
ans avec le numéro de clausus on a on a
la situation qu'on a sur les déserts
médicaux sur un certain nombre de
médicaments c'est pareil à partir du
moment où il y a des rémunérations pas
suffisantes sur un certain nombre de
médicaments les industriels de les
produisent plus en France voilà donc il
y a une réflexion à avoir sur ce sur ce
sujet ce projet là et puis aussi quelque
chose qui est peut-être un peu sur je
sais que sur tout ce qui est
paraserathanol etc il y a aussi une
nouvelle consommation en Chine depuis
l'explosion du covid en Chine qui
explique aussi voilà c'est décalages
mais je crois que ce qui est important
c'est qu'il faut pour être capable de
payer le juste prix si on veut pouvoir
retrouver une souveraineté et quand on
trouvera pas la souveraineté surtout
mais qu'il faut être capable de de de
savoir ce dont on est dépendant et de
savoir aussi que si on veut réguler par
le prix il y a un moment on aura une
difficulté parce que les les produits
iront chez d'autres autre sujet dont
vous parlez ce matin dans la montagne
c'est d'ailleurs la une Mathieu vous
êtes intéressé aux locations
saisonnières
ouais clairement en la matière il y a eu
un avant et un après covid depuis la
pandémie les locations de courte durée
on glissé des villes vers les campagnes
c'est très notable alors les locations
de courte durée principalement c'est
Airbnb et Abritel et le marché ténor
c'est simplement la France le deuxième
plus gros marché au monde derrière les
États-Unis alors pendant la pandémie le
tourisme international était à l'arrêt
mais le tourisme national lui il a
retrouvé des couleurs et c'est l'offre
rurale qui a tiré les marrons du feu
l'offre comme la demande d'ailleurs
quelques chiffres les offres dans
l'Allier où je me trouve ont augmenté de
près de 50% entre octobre 2019 et
octobre 2022 c'est plus de 70% dans le
Cher plus de 100% dans les Ardennes pour
prendre ces exemples là et dans le même
temps les grandes villes n'ont plus la
cote Paris notamment s'effondre à cause
du prix d'une nuité d'une part et à
cause de règles durcie avant la pandémie
d'autre part seul Marseille parmi ces
grandes villes parvient à s'en tirer
alors c'est une aubaine pour les
campagnes donc évidemment mais c'est
aussi toujours sujet à polémique là où
il est difficile de se loger à l'année
où là où les locations de courte durée
génèrent des crispations c'est le cas en
Bretagne c'est le cas sur le littoral et
dans le même temps les
multipropriétaires s'enrichissent alors
selon vous est-ce que c'est une bonne
chose pour le tourisme ou est-ce qu'il
faut mieux est-ce qu'il faut encadrer
davantage cette pratique
je pense qu'il faut l'encadrer je pense
qu'il faut l'encadrer parce
qu'effectivement sinon le fut dans les
villes ça peut se passer dans d'autres
endroits qui sont attractifs vous allez
avoir finalement
des des
habitations qui seront en fait des
hôtels cachés donc à partir de là
effectivement il faut les réguler il
faut les réguler avec une taxation
différente d'un certain nombre
d'endroits c'est c'était pendant ça a
été pendant des années une revendication
de nos élus parisiens parce que
effectivement ça pose un vrai problème
de voir une partie des logements
occupés de cette manière ça tire
l'ensemble du parc vers le haut
maintenant je dois dire aussi qu'il y a
un élément intéressant quand lorsque les
parce qu'il faut il faut différencier ce
qui est de la location d'une partie de
votre habitation principale de du fait
d'être propriétaire d'une habitation
pour pouvoir ensuite la mettre toute
l'année en location de cette manière
parce que si c'est une louer votre
habitation principale de temps en temps
c'est pas une mauvaise chose en
particulier ça peut vous aider à
financer enfin votre résidence
principale quand même aussi quelque
chose qui peut être intéressant donc il
faut faire la différence entre quelqu'un
qui loue une partie de sa résidence
principale où sa résidence principale de
temps en temps et puis un propriétaire
personnel ou
un investisseur qui en fait un métier
parce que s'il en fait un métier c'est
différent mais il faut le réguler
merci beaucoup on revoit la une de la
montagne location courte durée
là rurale c'est à la Une de votre
journal aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
Mathieu Perrineau on va terminer en
parlant de la situation en Ukraine
j'enlève le compte où vous êtes rendu
fin décembre dans quel état d'esprit
sont les Ukrainiens aujourd'hui toujours
très combatif toujours très compatible
et en même temps c'est assez étonnant de
voir à quel point malgré les
destructions systématique
d'infrastructures vitales en matière
électrique d'eau etc
bon cas ça marche
j'y suis allé en train je suis revenu en
train sans que ce soit des convois
particuliers ça fonctionne c'est à dire
que les services publics dans ce pays
fonctionne malgré tout avec une grosse
mobilisation et très compatible bien
entendu
même s'il souffre beaucoup plus qu'il y
a quelques mois parce que les
infrastructures civiles détruites ça ça
empêche énormément de choses et c'est
vrai que là il faisait pas
particulièrement froid lorsque je suis
passé et puis Kiev est quand même un peu
voilà le centre de Kev ils font il faut
ils essaient quand même que ça ça marche
même s'il y a beaucoup de de de
générateur d'électricité dans la dans
les rues pour pouvoir permettre au
restaurant de continuer à fonctionner
mais dans les campagnes j'ai visité une
petite une petite ville de de 48
habitants là pour le coup en terme
électrique c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
je le disais au début de cette interview
vous habitez en Pologne la Pologne qui
devrait livrer des chars à l'Ukraine la
France également est-ce qu'il faut y
voir un simple soutien ou est-ce qu'il
faut y voir une crainte de la part de
l'OTAN des Russes notamment avec
l'arrivée de nouveaux mobilisés de toute
façon je crois que
il est impossiblement indispensable
compte tenu de la situation de donner le
maximum de de d'équipement à l'Ukraine
pour qu'elle puisse tenir que lorsqu'on
voit lorsqu'on écoute des discours des
responsables russes on voit bien que ça
n'est pas juste un combat contre
l'Ukraine c'est un combat contre tout ce
que représente l'ensemble de l'Europe
son modèle de société ses libertés son
évolution
savoir si on veut le défendre ou pas
aujourd'hui les choses se passant du
crâne contenu de la situation
nous devons aider les sucres chrétiens
au maximum pour que les choses se
passent le plus rapidement possible
en espérant qu'un jour vous ayez à
Moscou
des vraies responsables c'est à dire des
gens qui sont capables de se rendre
compte que il faut revenir à la raison
et pour ça il faut avoir les moyens de
répondre à toutes éventualité et avec
résolution merci beaucoup on aura
évidemment l'occasion de parler de la
situation de reparler de cette situation
en Ukraine avec vous merci d'être venu
ce matin dans 20 minutes dans le club
des territoires on vous emmènera prendre
l'air prendre de l'altitude au sommet du
Mont Blanc ou quasi avec ce tramway vous
verrez les images et vous le voyez les
images sont magnifiques ce sera à la fin
de cette émission d'abord on va écrire
notre prochaine invité sur Roselyne
Bachelot